Game of Thrones night king isn't a
character known for his friendly face
and adorable smile and the extra weird
look he gave brand stark during the
Battle of Winterfell had everyone
wondering what was going on in his
frosty brain here's what was really
going on during that eerie exchange
you probably remember how the scene went
down bran sat beneath the weirwood tree
in the godswood of Winterfell waiting
the night King's arrival when the icy
villain finally approached he ambled
toward the youngest living stark man
before stopping and staring into his
eyes with an eerie look on his face an
expression most fans took is clear
intent to kill bran aka the three-eyed
Raven according to the night king
himself
Slovakian step man of Wladimir fir dick
that isn't exactly what was going on in
his own head verdict recently revealed
to vulture the real reason why the night
king looked at bran like he wanted to
turn his insides to icicles as it turns
out the night Kings glowering glare at
bran wasn't solely motivated by a desire
to kill an enemy in actuality the
strange look he gave bran was mostly the
result of some interesting direction
Furtick got ahead of shooting the scene
the director of the Battle of Winterfell
episode
Miguel supporing instructed Furtick to
walk toward bran stark actor Isaac
Hempstead right and imagine him as a
cake that he desperately wanted to eat
kind of weird right when Furtick breaks
it down though it's actually not the
oddest direction in the world and he was
clear in the interview that he considers
the posh Nick a quote great director who
gave him very good direction the actor
explained I remember a couple of times
when I did the walk and I go for my
target which was bran and he said bran
he is not man he is a cake and you would
like to eat this cake and I would like
to see you acting you're walking to him
you're walking like you're looking for
that cake which is waiting for you under
the tree verdict continued to elaborate
on the direction saying adults never run
for the cake they walk you can see from
an adult's body they're going for a cake
from grandmom and they're looking
forward to eating this cake when I walk
you can see what Miguel said don't be a
soldier no just walk confident there
a cake lemon cakes my favorite so you've
been telling me
verdict also shared that he's still not
sure that the night king even wanted to
kill bran in the first place
he said to vulture look we think he's
going to kill bran but who knows if he's
going to kill him he doesn't rush maybe
he had different plans maybe he wanted
to do something else you know
then arias start kills him but maybe he
was gonna show them no no no wait I'm
here for something else
just as Furtick received instruction on
how the night king should look at brand
during the tense sequence hemstead
wright also spoke at length with
director Sapna k-- to decide the way
bran should look back at the night king
the 20 year old actor revealed to the
New York Times that he and suppossed
quote came up with this idea that the
look brand gives the night King is one
of pity hemstead right further explained
bran saw the creation of the night king
or the first white Walker or whatever he
realizes that he was once just a normal
guy who was forcibly strapped to a tree
and had a piece of dragonglass plunged
in his heart he didn't ask to become
this raving crazy ice killer so we tried
to get a moment where bran is feeling
sorry for him bran is looking at this
ancient being who didn't want to become
this murderer but is while Hempstead
right acknowledged that the night King
did have it out for the three-eyed Raven
he offered another explanation as to why
he stopped to look at bran with that
haunting look on his face the reason the
night king takes so long is that he's
been programmed to destroy the
three-eyed Raven from the moment he was
created so he's taking a moment to savor
it
that pause wound up costing the night
King everything as it opened up a window
for Arya to attack and kill him plus
destroy his pack of White Walkers and
whites in the process just when you
think that Jon Snow is gonna be the hero
again we realize the Aria pairs through
mist in the end the night King didn't
get to have his cake or eat it and the
plants that sprouted through the snow
during the closing moments of the Game
of Thrones series finale seemed to
suggest that he never will
winter is over and the night king is
dead good job team y'all deserve a snack
for this one check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite shows are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a
single one
[Music]